bienvenue au sport le plus rapide au
monde
réservé aux meilleurs des meilleurs du
ciel
non mais c'est quoi ce délire
pour la première fois un avion vendeurs
t'apprendre parole à courrier montre la
casse s'est tu vas devoir affronter les
meilleurs joueurs du monde et passé le
vertige voilà vous êtes au courant que
ce vieil avion a besoin d aide oui il
suffit pas d'aller vite
je vais voir ce que tu as dans la
carlingue
fantastique il est prêt à regarder qui
voilà notre ami l'épandeur de style
propre aux paysans
bulldogs à bonjour
la plupart des gens m'appellent je suis
l touba câble on va vivre beaucoup
laventure ont marre ils combattent le
vert on va danser avec l'autre
andy est un rayon de soleil après toute
une vie dans les ténèbres ou bien un
verre d'engrais frais dans un pré
d'herbe desséché n'était même pas des
chats mais aurait attaqué telle reprise
à tous donc été que sa firme était une
voiture
il a un léger problème d'identité tu
crois vraiment que tu peux battre voilà
désormais à jamais et il est né
populaire
dans sa campagne open
ici deux sticks repos peur
je m'associe la tempête
c'est une super histoire daoud cider
c'est comme blanche neige
mais il ya des nains
c'est pestilence
je fais dans la vie mon garçon suis
plaint je ne pleure jamais je suis
anglais